I have a ton of non-Trump news to discuss
with you today, and in a moment, we're going
to be focusing in on Arizona and the Senate
race that's going on in Arizona.
But before I do that, I want to talk about
the Senate more broadly a little bit.
I don't know with everything that's going
on.
How many people in my audience are following
what's going on with the Senate for November
of 2020.
But it is increasingly clear that if we all
come together, if we do the hard work, if
we do the phone banking, if we get out there
and vote, there is a realistic shot that Republicans
could lose control of the Senate in November.
Now, a year ago, when we were talking about
this, I was mostly saying it's like a 5 percent
chance.
I mean, Democrats could take the Senate, but
really we're we're probably going to have
to wait until 2022 to see Republicans lose
control of the Senate.
And then six months ago, things that shifted
a little bit.
I did a segment pointing out it's in play.
It's probably still like a 20 percent shot
at taking the Senate for Democrats.
There is now an increasingly realistic scenario
where Democrats snatch control of the Senate
from Republicans in November.
Now, to refresh the numbers, right now, the
balance of power is 53 to 47 in favor of Republicans.
That is the 47 is 45 Democrats and then two
independents, Bernie Sanders and Angus King.
That's how you get to 47.
If the Senate is tied 50/50, the vise president
gets to cast the tie breaking vote.
So right now, if Democrats want control, they
need a net gain of four seats or three seats
plus the presidency, because then Joe Biden's
vise president becomes the tiebreaker in a
50 50 Senate.
Now Democrats are going to lose Alabama.
This is just a reality, Alabama.
There's this Senate seat that used to be Jeff
Sessions seat.
Republican Jeff Sessions became Trump's beleaguered
attorney general.
Doug Jones defeated serial accused sex assaulter
Roy Moore.
But that is an anomaly, an anomaly, depending
on how you like to pronounce it.
And Jeff Sessions is running for that seat
again.
And he's almost certain to win.
He's winning by a ton.
So in practice, losing that one.
This means Democrats need five wins against
Republicans or four wins plus the presidency.
And it is not a crazy scenario at this point
to imagine that that might happen.
It would be a major turn of events from what
we would have been looking at six months ago
in great part.
You would blame Trump, you could blame the
virus.
But Republicans have a very difficult path
now to defending control of the Senate compared
to six or twelve months ago.
You've got 100 senators.
They serve six year terms.
That means every two years, a third of the
Senate is up for reelection.
Right now, we have 33 races plus two special
elections, Arizona and Georgia.
And of those, 35 Republicans have to defend
23, whereas Democrats are only defending 12.
In other words, Republicans have 23 seats
they could lose, whereas Democrats have only
12 seats that they could lose.
Now, I've already mentioned Alabama and Democrats,
almost certainly Democrats are going to lose
that Alabama Senate seat.
Let's look at the best shots for Democrats
to take seats from Republicans.
First of all, you've got Colorado where John
Hickenlooper, the Democrat, is leading the
incumbent Republican, Cory Gardner, by 13.
That will very likely flip in Arizona.
Mark Kelly is leading Martha McSally, the
incumbent Republican, by an average of nine.
Now in one recent poll, it's 13 and we'll
talk about that a little later.
In Maine, you have Sarah Gideon, the Democratic
challenger to longtime Republican Senator
Susan Collins, ahead by about two and a half.
And then in North Carolina, it's very close.
Cal Cunningham, the Democratic challenger
ahead of incumbent Republican Senator Thom
Tillis by one.
I mean, that's like a tie.
It's the margin of error.
Then you've got some longer shots for Democrats
in terms of the longer shots in Montana.
Steve Bullock has a very good recent poll
against the incumbent Republican, Steve Daines.
I'm still calling it a longshot because it
is just one poll and it is Montana.
But Montana doesn't look bad for Democrats.
Then you've got Georgia, Kansas and Iowa,
which are, as we're calling them.
Those are long shots for Democrats, but they
are not completely impossible.
So the news is the Senate is very much in
play.
It's very much worth fighting for.
This has been a big reversal over the last
six.
And particularly if you look at what the polling
was 12 months ago, but voters need to vote
otherwise.
This is nothing.
This is going to be another opportunity lost
if people don't get out and vote.
I don't want to see that happen.
Now, let's focus in on one Senate race, and
I'll use it to look more broadly at the signal
that the Senate races could.
Send about the presidential race.
Let's dig into Arizona right now